un expediente judicial de 27 páginas
acusada al departamento de justicia de
eeuu y al fbi de actuar de forma
agresiva e injusta donald trump y sus
abogados exigen que el fbi detenga la
revisión de los documentos sustraídos de
mar a lago y piden que se designe a un
abogado independiente para revisarlos
las fuerzas del orden son un escudo que
protege a américa no puede utilizarse
como arma con fines políticos por lo
tanto solicitamos asistencia judicial
tras una redada innecesaria y sin
precedentes la moción también exige una
lista más detallada de los documentos
retenidos y la devolución de cualquiera
que esté fuera del alcance de la orden
de allanamiento del fbi la demanda se
presentó en momentos cuando the new york
times reveló que el gobierno ha
recuperado más de 300 documentos
clasificados desde que trump dejó el
cargo entre los que se incluyen informes
de la cia el fbi y otros servicios de
inteligencia se espera que donald trump
anuncie su intención de postularse de
nuevo para la presidencia en 2024 y sus
partidarios sigue convencidos de que la
investigación en su contra tiene
intereses políticos